bro i hit someone with eucalyptus though
on stream
it felt so good did you really i felt so
good
who'd you get someone was like hey it's
my birthday what did you get me
i was like oh i'm like uh alina got you
some eucalyptus and then elaine's like
eucalypt i'm like yeah
you could lift this dick
[Laughter]
and it was great because it was
one-sided like there was
there was no they couldn't donate fast
enough to be like i know what eucalyptus
is yeah yeah
yeah no it's like you got you got owned
yeah yeah take that one to sleep yeah
you know what i love is the idea of
someone just you know
throwing out a quick 500 bits and then
they go hey man
what'd you get for my birthday and
they're all excited and i hit him with
eucalyptus dick and they're just sitting
in their room looking at their phone
like
oh damn
and then they gotta go down for dinner
and they're like what are you doing
upstairs i was like um
thinking about eucalyptus uh no yeah
they do it to their parents that's the
only way you can feel better about it
that's what i do yeah
i use the ones you use on me on my
friends and then they
laugh and i'm like okay yeah yeah
anymore
it's the worst when someone doesn't get
it yeah they're like
malone brown what malone brown dick in
here what do you mean
malone brown dick in your mouth what
does that mean yeah i'm like malone
brown
yeah malone brown dude dude dude that's
why i wanted to bring up the [ __ ]
ihop thing
did you see that tick tock where that
guy was in that uh what the [ __ ] did he
call it
it was like uh it was like some [ __ ]
omelette it was like some name it would
look
disgusting you know what i'm talking
about it had like [ __ ] like
[ __ ] oh it was [ __ ] foul okay
it was a tick-tock yeah [ __ ]
ah i didn't see it it was like it was
like
was it it's like something omelette like
a denver on omelette
oh it was i'mma let you let this dick no
i [ __ ] it up i will let you lick this
dick
i'm listen you own
i'm happy you [ __ ] it up because i
don't feel like i can give you that one
fully no you can't but i was just
i was trying to curveball it i know you
[ __ ] i mean i feel like you still got me
[Music]
i'm sorry you guys you guys have to
understand these are like these are
fan submissions i can't tell you how
many messages i get
like hey i'm gonna let you let this i'm
gonna let you let this dick it's a hard
one it's a hard one
i'm gonna let you like yeah that was i'm
gonna let you lick this dick
god that's good dude [ __ ] i almost
damn i almost just got god he said
denver omelette
that was like a den for denver i should
have slowed it down it just said nah um
i'm gonna let you lick this dick
guys you have to understand because you
know in previous days
cody would try to get me with the sigma
and i always go
man come on we know this we know this
but now everyone's giving me these
clever submissions
like someone someone messaged me that he
was like hey man you should hit him with
omelette
i was like oh that's [ __ ] cold
and some other girl was like you should
use eucalyptus that's a hard one but
i was like i don't think i'm again with
eucalyptus but i need that one
so you know there was a there was a
moment this weekend where somebody said
something a word and i i thought to
myself i'm like damn that could
that could be it yeah see it wasn't all
the way there
it was it was the second half you know
it was like a two word thing
oh okay it was like a name it was like a
name like malone brown right okay i
forget what it was but i sat there for
like 45 minutes
drunk as [ __ ] like yeah we're like
playing a drinking game and i'm zoned
out
trying to think of this and they're like
cody and i'm like what's up
see you spin your turn you're supposed
to do never have i ever whatever and i'm
like oh well i'm just what are we
what are we doing what are we playing
and then i go right back
to it and i didn't i didn't figure it
out bro now you know my vibe
when i was thinking of the malone brown
setup you know it's just it's
totally it just takes you over like you
did
something [ __ ] yeah but it feels you
know
it's it's going to be a big payoff if it
works oh it feels so good yeah
yeah so good it's i think i think it's
i would almost say it's meaner to do
in a private context like with just your
friends
because you know i feel like in you know
in this context for like a
video or like a podcast it's like oh
okay it's a joke
shared amongst all of us remember malone
brown but to like
hit someone with malone brown just in
the middle of their day one on one
and then you just continue to hang out
with that person that's kind of [ __ ]
mean
it is it is kind of
it's like establishing like i'm better
than you yeah it's like yeah it's
completely
if i just cucked you in front of the
whole group
[Laughter]
yeah i'm the alpha i'm the alpha yeah
you